las relaciones con china preocupan
enormemente a la Unión Europea es un
país al que consideran un socio pero
también un competidor y un rival
sistémico especialmente en materia
comercial especialmente también por su
influencia en el este asiático pero
también en su influencia en varias
regiones del mundo entre ellas también
América Latina por ello la Unión Europea
quiere estar muy vigilante Aunque sus
relaciones también pueden ser de socios
han asegurado los líderes europeos
especialmente por ejemplo en la lucha
contra el cambio climático en cualquier
caso el presidente del Consejo europeo
Charles Michel asegura que no podemos
tener unas relaciones Eternamente de
contrincantes ha asegurado pero aún así
hay que ser vigilantes y por ello ha
dicho que no se pueden tejer relaciones
de excesiva dependencia por ejemplo en
materia tecnológica porque ya se ha
podido ver con Rusia que la excesiva
dependencia luego puede pasar factura Y
por eso ha asegurado que hay que tejer
mayores relaciones con otras regiones
del mundo y ha puesto como ejemplo por
ejemplo las relaciones con América
Latina unas relaciones que considera
clave sobre todo de cara al año que
vienen que España va a tener la
presidencia del Consejo europeo y ya se
espera una Cumbre entre la Unión Europea
y los países de a nivel de jefes de
estado de gobierno algo que no ocurre
desde 2015 además como prueba de esta
mejora de las relaciones entre la Unión
Europea de América Latina la
representante para la política exterior
josep borrell viajará de hecho el lunes
para una Ministerial de la celac y
viajará a Argentina y a Uruguay como
prueba de esta mejora de las relaciones
Esther también se anunció un nuevo
paquete de ayudas para Ucrania Con qué
se comprometieron los líderes
si los líderes europeos insisten en que
van a ayudar al cueste lo que cueste a
Ucrania en todas las medidas posibles
entre ellas también financieramente y
por ello la presente la comisión
europeander ha dicho que van a estudiar
un nuevo paquete de ayuda a ucrade de
18.000 millones de euros de cara al año
que viene Aproximadamente a Ucrania
necesita unos 3-4000 millones de euros
al mes aproximadamente para hacer frente
a pagos o corrientes la Unión Europea Se
compromete a este paquete Aunque hay que
estudiar Cómo se va a poder hacer porque
Hasta ahora ha habido otros paquetes de
ayuda por ejemplo Hay un plan de 9000
millones de euros del que aún se tienen
que desembolsar 3000 millones de video
las reticencias de Alemania sobre que
necesita más en garantías sobre cómo se
va a poder dar este dinero Porque
algunos países creen que deberían ser
préstamos pero Alemania existe que
deberían ser préstamos sino subsidios
por lo tanto hay que ver cómo se va a
poder hacer esto la presente
dice que los ministros de finanzas van a
poder estudiar este nuevo instrumento de
ayuda a Ucrania